donc finalement pour désinfecter les
produits c'est l'expérience magasinage
en temps de covè 19 désinfectant
plexiglas deux mains et c'est finalement
autour des commerçants du grand montréal
du moins ceux qui ont pignon sur rue on
est vraiment vous savez c'est ici on est
tellement eu de faux départ jouer tous
ces faux départs dans le domaine du
sport qu'est le présentement le procès
c'est demain et montréal se fait belle
le centre ville aussi se prépare on dit
aussi que les rues soient prêtes pour
accueillir le public
c'est pour ça qu'on a on a décidé de
créer un mobilier adapté convivial pour
gérer les files d'attentes mais le
retour sera progressif et demeure
incertain
on va pas s'attendre à ce qu'ils aient
un retour massif des travailleurs il
faut savoir que le centre-ville c'est
quand même 400 mille travailleurs en
temps normal quotidiennement qui le
fréquentent
donc ça va avoir un impact
nécessairement sur les cafés les
restaurants le midi sur la plaza
st-hubert c'était déjà difficile avant
la crise
cuisine haïtienne survit grâce aux
livraisons malgré les travaux et la
cabine
mais claudia ferri n'a pas beaucoup
d'espoir de voir ses voisins ouvrir
lundi et j'ai entendu que déjà beaucoup
de location ils ont formé par mois les
magasins au tour ici c'est plus chaud
pour mariages les robes de mariage sow
ya pas de mariage se dit cet été il n'ya
pas de prom saut pour la rue saint-denis
aussi les temps sont durs malgré les
aides d'urgence
on en a deux confirmé il y en a trois
qui sont
qui sont dans une situation précaire je
pense que tout le monde veut rouvrir
c'est comment ça va se passer au courant
de l'année parce que le spectre d'une
deuxième bague d'une autre fermeture
plane toujours
au début c'est que l'achalandage est
moindre mais les gens savent plus ce
qu'ils veulent louis côté n'a d'autre
choix que d'être optimiste et de miser
sur la relance aussi imprévisible soit m
si jacques andré charbonneau radio
canada mon frère